in northern Canada winter slowly loosens
its grip and a young polar bear is
hungry sniffs a meal already in progress
and decides to play a dangerous game of
food snatch his opponent is larger older
and won't tolerate a rival second try he
scores a quick nibble it is a game of
patience and cunning but a loss result
is death adult males would kill younger
bears if it suits them the older male
has had enough he charges fishy
adolescent further and further back
[Music]
the young one admits defeat and retreats
to say frown he begins a new game a
waiting game
the older bear devours his meal licking
the carcass clean of blubber when the
adult male has had his fill he wanders
off leaving the scraps for his opponent
the young one feeds on the remains it
wins a consolation prize of sorts a full
belly but it will be a long time before
it's ready to compete again